When female mosquitoes poke their proboscis
through your skin so they can suck some of
your blood to be later used to make eggs,
they inject you with some of their saliva.
This saliva helps them to drink your blood
more quickly, because it contains a cocktail
of anticoagulants.
Once the female mosquito is full up of your
blood or is disturbed, she flies away, leaving
some of her saliva behind.
Your body then kicks your immune system in
gear as a response to the presence of this
saliva.
It produces various antibodies which in turn
bind to the antigens in the mosquito’s saliva.
This then triggers the release of histamine.
Histamine is a nitrogen compound that, among
other things, triggers an inflammatory response.
It also helps white blood cells and other
proteins to engage invaders in your body by
making the capillaries of these cells more
permeable.
Bottom line, the histamine ends up making
the blood vessels near the bite swell up.
This produces a pink, itchy bump where the
mosquito poked you.
Scratching the bump only makes this worse
because it causes more irritation and inflammation
of the sight, resulting in your immune system
thinking it needs more antibodies to get rid
of the foreign protein.
So the more you scratch, the more it will
swell; the itchier it will get; and the longer
it will last.
Only female mosquitoes drink blood.
They don’t need the blood for their own
nourishment; rather, they need it to be able
to produce eggs.
Once the female has safely acquired a “blood
meal”, she will rest for a few days while
her body develops the eggs from digesting
the proteins and iron in the blood, producing
amino acids which are used as the building
blocks for the synthesis of the egg yolk proteins.
Male and female mosquitoes alike get their
nourishment from plant nectar and other sugar
sources.